Wow there are a lot of you here yes
every year we come to comic-con and
we've announced the next season of Teen
Wolf and every year we've been able to
celebrate with the fans and this season
this year is a little different but no
less reason to celebrate we're gonna hit
a hundred episodes at the end of season
six
and we've also and we've decided that a
hundred episodes is also a good place to
stop yeah this will be the final these
next twenty episodes will be the final
season of Teen Wolf yeah I know
we're we're sad about it and it's
bittersweet but we were so happy to be
able to come to comic-con and share it
with you guys I'm gonna start to cry I
think so yeah this is it this is the
regime that we've built everybody that
we've put in these seats it's coming to
an end and I just wanted let everybody
know it from Jeff and everybody here's
heart that this has been the biggest
movement that we've ever been a part of
this isn't just a show this is a family
you guys are all a part of it you guys
have helped us get to this point and and
I hope you guys know that we love you
guys I do crazy [ __ ] like this because I
want to make you guys smile and laugh
you just you mean so much to me and so
so this ending is the end of a huge era
for all of us and me me specifically
because this is you know I care so much
so deeply about this show and want to be
the leader of this show so I'm gonna
have to find something else to be a
leader of when this is over but this is
this is huge
I love each and every single one of you
and I want to come and hug every single
one of you when this is over but
we also we should probably say a word
we Tyler has been talking to Dylan I've
texted with Dylan and told him the news
and we've all like Dylan sent the most
beautiful message about how bittersweet
it was and how what an amazing thing
we've been able to do we miss him here
we wish you can come but he's still at
home recuperating and I've got to ask
since Holland was has been here from the
beginning - I want to say something
about this Michele oh gosh I mean I grew
up with this like just getting a boy so
basically in my entire 20s and I was a
boy back then so you're still avoid Jeff
and it's it's been the craziest ride I
probably wouldn't be acting if it wasn't
for this show and she wouldn't actually
she was still in college and we kept
telling her that she didn't have to go
back even an even a season one was going
on I actually uh one of my professors
had a former producer on the pilot
Proctor my exam in between takes and
they actually became really good friends
my professor and this producer of teeth
wolf because of they had to go back and
forth on email about my mmm exam and
that it did not cheat he watching
tickets and so yeah I mean now I'll be
I'm going in my 30s now and I've spent
my entire almost an entire decade us for
eight years I audition for the show in
2009 so it's it's literally been the
most significant part of my adult life
and I structure my life around what year
of Teen Wolf it was and you know it's
it's just I'm kind of in that stage
right now but it's been a it's been a
wild ride and I I just can't thank Jeff
and the boys enough for making it such a
beautiful beautiful chapter - my my
story
you
you